welcome everybody we'll just give robin
a few minutes before we get started with
our announcements
then on to our speaker uh we gotta we'll
get going right away as soon as everyone
gets in
hope everyone's having a wonderful april
i hope it's uh trying to be a good month
for you both weather-wise work-wise
life-wise pandemic-wise hopefully things
are going okay for you
hopefully vaccination-wise totally all
the things are starting to look better
without letting down our guard hopefully
everyone will just be able to have
you know good april um and moving on
into the rest of spring and summer
so people are starting to fill in good
to see everybody well
as much as i can see you um oh hey matt
you're here mattify some people
try to point out names i see i'm not
gonna get everyone i see because that'd
be impossible but michael paul good to
see you
let's see who else is in this name list
here
all right now ian good to see you here
emil so lots of people here i've seen
before and lots of new people and other
people who just use their first names
i might know you i might not know you
and other people two names some of you i
know some of you i don't know but it's
good to see everyone as much as possible
thank you all for coming to our april
meetup
so before we get started with our
speaker we have just a few
announcements to make those of you who
used to come in person
you know we always start the meetup with
who is hiring
obviously we can't have everyone jump up
and down
and shout who's hiring in the zoom
meeting so please go into the slack the
nyhakar slack
go to the job postings channel and post
your job there
let us know if you're hiring what type
of job you're trying to fill
and if you're looking to get a job go to
the job postings channel and see who's
posting up there
we have people post you know all the
time and there's always good jobs to be
filled and it's a good match of
a good hopefully good employee hopefully
a good company and everyone is in a good
place
so everyone go and look for that
if you're interested in looking at a job
at lander analytics my company i'm going
to take a shameless plug here
we are looking to hire a data scientist
a linux person and a technical
salesperson
so if you're interested in any of those
roles
be in touch with me i think you all know
how to find me by now um again
data scientists linux roles and um
a technical sales role so if you're
actually you like doing data science you
like doing some sales stuff let me know
um all right so that's job postings
again if you have job postings go to the
job postings channel
next up i know we can't be here all
together in person but i got my pizza
we'll do a cheese lock test
the cheese is holding on quite nicely
this is a vodka slice one that has
different properties with cheese lock
you see some good charring on the back
so i'm very happy this
this slice here this is from a place
called vitos
so i've been enjoying that pie so
everyone is enjoying your pizza or your
regional specialty
i hope everyone's having something good
again since we can't be with each other
which is a
shame uh we're going to try to keep a
conversation going so if you want to
have a conversation want to talk to
people
in the ny hacker slack when by the way
if you're not a member of the ny hacker
slack
you can join it by going to ny
hackard.org there is a link there
um i will uh nicole actually you can
post up the link to the slack into the
zoom chat that'd be really awesome uh so
there is a channel
in the ny hacker slack called monthly
meetup chat
go there and talk about what's going on
here talk about cool things talk about
things you want to understand better
and speaking of talking about things if
you have questions
arising from this talk i understand that
we can't all ask the question so
in that chat room in that one it is
uh the event meetup so nicole just
posted a link
in that chat room the monthly meetup
chat is the name of the room
ask the questions there and i will
collate them
and ask the questions at the end of the
end of the night and get all your
questions answered all right
so if you have a burning question ask it
i know my computer is
beeping a lot i will turn that off right
now i apologize
everybody i'll make sure that thing
doesn't beep anymore
and if you have any questions ask them
in the monthly meetup chat or if you're
not a member of the slack which i highly
recommend
you could ask it right here in zoom i
will collect all the questions and ask
them at the very end
the video for this meetup will be posted
in a few days just takes a little bit of
time to download it and
do any uh cutting of the video if we
need to that should be up in just a few
days at ny hackard.org
on our youtube channel so stay stay
tuned for that
next month we have scheduled i believe
it's may 17th
don't quote me on that tomorrow i'll
announce it officially it should be may
17th
will be james lamb talking about light
gbm
so if you're sick of xg boost you're not
into cap boost
light gbm is there for you it is a
boosted tree algorithm
comes out of the microsoft open source
team and it runs an
r on the cpu and even the gpu so that'll
be very exciting
later this year we have begun planning
for the new york r conference you see my
shirt i'm wearing it today i'm wearing
almost every day let's make
be honest very different colors of the
shirt make up a large chunk of my
wardrobe
all right we have our conference coming
up later this year we are getting ready
to make some announcements about that
no details for you yet we're still
planning it all out but stay tuned we'll
be announcing that
soon ish whatever tune means uh but we
will be getting that out to you and
we're hopefully uh doing something
really good this year
so with all those announcements remember
post a job in the job posting channel
chat in the monthly meetup chat enjoy
your pizza come back next month for
james and we're about to get started
so our next speaker came about because
i was on twitter and i saw someone talk
about ruston r
and klaus our speaker answered
and i'm like do you want to give a talk
about this at the meetup and he agreed
like six months ago so we're all very
happy to have him here
everyone's totally in for a lot of fun
of two languages that start with the
letter r
so it's really great how well they go
together everyone please give a warm
virtual welcome to class
yeah thanks a lot for having me
are you are you done with your
introduction am i ready to go
call you now just wait to make sure you
get your video shared then i will drop
off the video
and enjoy very good let me see
if it works the way that i think it's
going to work
okay how does this look it looks like a
beautiful sharingan document
like a real presentation okay
let me see if i can have the chat up
here i
always find zoom so confusing the moment
you start sharing your screen everything
just goes all over the place it just
disappears and you can't get to it
you're great
okay so yes i'm going to talk about the
extender project
integrating r and rust and i believe
when jared reached out to me originally
about giving this presentation i didn't
even know
about extender yet so this it existed
already i believe but i definitely
wasn't part of it i was doing some other
things and
i'll be talking about this and i thought
it would be good to start with
just a good origin story how did i get
myself
into this mess right why am i talking
about ah and rust that's not really
normally what i do
so many of you may or may not know me
from gdplot and data visualization
those are topics that i tweet a lot
about and have done
quite some work written various packages
and that's really
what got me into this mess that i wrote
this
package gdtext a while back which
allows you to do styling of gdpr text
elements with inline css so i have a
quick example here don't really want to
read through all the code
but the main point is you can write this
simple html
like here i'm making a strong element
and i'm
applying a style and the style has some
color here
and then when you run this
you get for example a faceted gg plot
plot where the facet labels
are in the color of the data points
great so that i wrote that a while back
and that
is on cran and people use it and like it
but i wasn't really satisfied with this
because
i thought it would be so much nicer if i
could use css selectors and what i mean
by that is
i would want to be able to write css
where just have
css classes that and i'm assuming you
know css if you don't
this is the the last slide about css and
html so if this means nothing to you
you can just zone out and soon i'll talk
about different stuff
but if you know css you may appreciate
the
the elegance of something like that
where maybe you have
css classes that correspond to values in
your data and then you have whatever
styling you want
and then you simply
have some sort of element where you you
drop in
as the class the value from your
variable
and then it applies the styling and you
get something like this
so so that's really and you see here now
i'm actually setting the background
color
and the foreground color if it's a light
background
then i need a black color if it's a dark
background i need a white color and so
on this
is so much easier to work with and you
the basically the plotting code never
has to change
you just need to change the styling and
so i i actually have
sort of a proof of concept of this
working and
eventually probably it will also be on
crown like in
in 10 years or so it it may be there um
but the point is this was my goal right
and this was what i was thinking about
sort of
last spring coming into the summer
and then i was like okay how can i
implement this well i need some sort of
library that can pass css and
connect it to an html uh
dom like your html documentary
and there's no r package that does css
and my gta text package was written in c
plus plus so i looked well is the c
plus plus code that can do this no i
couldn't really find anything and
probably that was good that i couldn't
find anything but then
eventually i came across this project
called servo
i don't know if you've heard of that so
that is
i don't actually know how a life it
still is they just recently laid off a
lot of people but
um that is or was mozilla's
attempt to rewrite a web browser from
scratch
and so as part of that they they
actually have like an
a browser grade html parser it's this
html5ever
html5 parser and they also have a
browser grade rust passer this
uh sorry freudian mistake
browser grade css parser and it's called
rust css
passer because it's implemented in rust
and what is rust
rust is actually the language that
mozilla
designed to write the new web browser so
it's
a language specifically designed to
write a web browser so
maybe that's a good language to to write
something that like passes
html css and then displays it if the
language was specifically written
for that and so that's how i
that's how i came across rust and that's
how i started using it and it
turns out this actually does work really
well and so
this proof of concept code that i just
showed you earlier it actually is using
this html parser and it's using this css
parser and i actually have full support
for
css level 3 selectors in there so it
works really well other things
don't work so well but that's a separate
topic
but so i had to learn rust and had to
learn how to make
rust talk to r to start
working on this project and so in the
process
i've gotten really excited about rust i
think rust
is really a next generation language
that
that will be very important in many
applications in the future and so
in large part i'm assuming that most of
you are coming from the r
side and not from the rust side and so
mostly i just want to talk about
rust why i think it's an exciting
language
what are the pros what are the cons and
then i'll also show you how
how you can connect it with that so
let's start with the benefits what are
the benefits of r so it's
compiled and has the performance of c
it can actually sometimes be faster than
c
like it it really like the
founding principle of r is uh sorry of
rust
is no compromise is performance like
the the overarching goal of rust or one
it has
kind of two overarching goals but number
one is
no overhead absolute maximum performance
that you can have
while having absolute protection against
undefined behavior so normally the
problem with c
is or c plus plus it's great you can
write c
code it's super fast it's a hundred
times faster a thousand times faster
than
r but you have to work with
pointers and memory allocation and
the moment you have more than five lines
of code
every other time you make a change your
code crashes
something blows up the sky falls i mean
that's just the problem with c
and c plus plus and many of these
languages that
that are optimized for maximum
performance and
uh with rust from the get go
the point was that that the language
designers wanted to
avoid that at all cost like the language
should never create
any unbe undefined behavior and it gets
in particular
important and i don't remember if i have
a bullet point here or not because i
personally don't care so much about that
but
some people do care a lot gets really
tricky when you have
a parallel code execution right if
if you have multiple threads and you
have memory maybe that is shared across
threats and you want to be sure that you
never have any race conditions
but you also be want to be really fast
it's basically a nightmare in cnc plus
plus and
i heard that even google is starting to
to
move some of their chrome code to rust
because they're running into the problem
that like in c
plus basically you cannot write large
thread safe memory save code it just
basically the language gets in the way
it doesn't work
um you have modern obstruction generics
containers functional programming so
even though it's a
like close to the metal language you can
write
pretty high level code that that
so it's a very expressive language that
allows you to do a lot of complex things
with
with not that much code there's a
powerful macro programming language so
everybody who has ever programmed c
knows the great c
programming language uh c macro language
that basically
is just a regex it just like drops
some text in place of keywords and then
everything can go wrong and in in rust
it's really
built in to the compiler and so the
compiler passes
your macros and then processes them in
sort of an intelligent way and so that
allows you
to to do meta programming basically you
can write
code that computes on code
but then it gets compiled safely and the
compiler knows what is an identifier
and what is an operator and so on as it
processes the macro
there's an integrated build environment
and dependency management
and that's really beautiful because
anybody who has written
c or c plus plus knows like the fun of
juggling make files
and and trying to integrate third-party
libraries
and then you have three different c
libraries that you want to integrate and
they all have a different
build structure and then you need to
write
some sort of build system that like
calls their respective build systems and
builds these
and in rust all of that is taken care of
for you basically if you have
a working rust setup you can compile
any rust library and you can
integrate dependencies other rust
libraries it usually is just you add one
line of code you just say i want this
dependency
and the build system takes care of
downloading it downloading all the
dependencies compiling everything
but it's that really removes so many
headaches
that alone is actually worth probably
switching over to rest it's actually in
many ways similar to what you have in
r right if you have a working r
installation
you know you can just go
install.packages and if it's on cran
you can install it with one line of code
and it will run
it's sort of the same in rust the one
thing that rust has overall
is that it has an archive of
all versions of all libraries that
have ever been published and when you
specify a dependency you usually specify
exactly the version that you want
and so your code continues to compile
and run
even if upstream they have made some
changes and have
released a new version you have to
essentially opt
in to the next version and so that
that makes it very reliable like
i'm my code uses some version of the
rust css
parser and i don't care if they have
since then released
a new version or whatever my code will
compile just
as always and at some point i can
switch to the new version and maybe have
to fix any binary and
compatible issues or not i can just
also keep using the old version if i
want to
there's a built-in framework for unit
tests which i also really appreciate
like you
don't have basically a lot of the things
where in c
or c plus plus there's a hundred choices
that you have to make
like what unit test framework do i use
what do i use for this what build
framework do you use all of this
is just built in trust and there's just
one choice and that's how everybody does
it and it's very simple
and there's also a built-in framework
for documentation and distribution
and i just wanted to show you this
quickly so it's called
the website is called crates.io and this
is
as an example this rust css parser and
there's 92 versions that have been
published so you see all the versions
here
um the dependencies so these are the
dependencies that the rust css
parser depends on which are also all on
crates
and so on you can see which other
projects are using
this and then you have the documentation
here which is standard rust
documentation which is just
automatically generated from
the source code it's it's very similar
if you're familiar with any sort of
actually if you're familiar with how it
works in r where you have your
documentation
integrated into the code and then it
automatically gets built when the
package gets built
it's basically the same in rust
okay these are all the benefits
but there's a big but the the butt is in
a larger font
learning rust can be a steep climb so
this is not a programming language that
you pick up over the weekend
like i bought a thick book and i
literally
read the book cover to cover and that
and slowly started to learn it like you
really have to learn from scratch
and i would say in particular if you
have a lot of experience writing code in
c or c plus or so there's going to be a
lot of things that you have to unlearn
so that's that's one of the
downsides i would say and the other
downside is
so um there's
there's a lot of pros and you get really
high performance you get
all this protection against memory
errors and so on
that necessarily comes with some
overhead
so i would not use rust
to do a quick data analysis i have some
data table and i quickly need to
calculate some means or make a graph or
so
rust is not going to be the right
language for that
everything is going to be a bit more
involved and i'll show you some examples
of that in a few minutes
but if you have some serious
large scale or high performance needs
project
the additional effort is probably worth
it
now some people think well it's just
like c plus plus
i've i've heard people say that and it's
actually really important to understand
that it's not even though
superficially so this on the right is
some rust code and you look at it and
you might say oh but it sort of looks
like c
plus plus right here i have a struct and
actually the struct and rust
is pretty much the same as a struct in c
or c plus plus
you have curly braces well that looks
familiar you have these
angular braces and they are basically
templates in c
plus like like templates in c plus plus
so
there's a lot of stuff that
superficially looks similar
and i would say that's probably um
part of of where it really is deceptive
and where you can
think it works the way you think it
works and then it doesn't
and so let's do some examples so here i
have a simple
rust program multiples of three and five
so i want to calculate the
the multiples of three and five and i've
set this up in the rust playground so
it's another great thing of the
of the rust ecosystem everything is just
so nicely set up and built
so this is a website where i've set up
the code and i can run it it's a
compiled language so
it takes a few moments it has compiled
it and this is the output so what is the
output here 3
5 6 9 10 12 15. so these are
all the numbers that are multiples of
threes
and or fives you may
remember this from the fizzbuzz problem
that is often
posed in to to job candidates and job
interviews and we and we'll get to that
in a second
so this is the output three five six
nine ten okay so what does it do
okay i'm setting up here um
so in rust like one thing that is really
beautiful and rust even though it's a
strongly typed language it typically
figures out the type for you so i'm just
writing let x
equals and then this is a range one dot
dot
to infinity i don't i'm not giving an
end value so
um it just goes to infinity and r
the rust compiler figures out what x is
i don't have to worry about it
and then here y
i say is a vector and then the
underscore is again
like the rust compiler is going to
figure out a vector of
what this is i don't need to worry about
it
i take x i convert it into an iterator
so x is a range right so it's like in
this actually very similar to what you
may know from python
you set up a range and then you iterate
over the values so i
set up an iterator now i filter
and filter is functional programming i
give it
a lambda function here a closure
which takes some argument z and then
does a computation
on z so if x modulo 3
is 0 or sorry z modulo 3 or
z modulo 5 is 0 then it returns
true and otherwise it returns false so
it basically tests
so it iterates over the numbers one two
three four five it tests are they
divisible by three or five
and then i take 10 that means i take the
first
10 elements that survive this filter and
then i collect
and collect means get this stuff that an
iterator is giving you and turning
into a vector and so now is a vector and
y is a vector and i can print it out and
then i have this vector of all the
multiples of three fives and so on
um and you may appreciate that this is
really
fairly high language high level language
code right
iterators filters and so on
i didn't have to write a for loop here
um it's
functional programming okay so now i put
on my
c or c plus plus program i had and i go
okay
i'm printing out why but
let me also print out x i'm curiou
really curious like
how is rust going to print out this
range right
okay so let me uncomment this i want to
print out
x and there's the the typical mistake
that a c or c plus plus programmer will
make when they first
encounter rust so this doesn't compile
right now you might say oh probably you
just can't
print a range right maybe that's the
problem so let's like
put the print over here can we actually
print
um we can print ranges just fine they're
just printed like this
one dot dot so that's not the problem
okay so then now okay i guess we have to
read
what the error message actually is
now the rust compiler is fantastic it
really tells you exactly what the
problem is
borrow of moved value x okay that makes
no sense for anybody who doesn't know
rust but this is
like very much rust so let
x equals one dot dot
and it says move occurs because x has
type
range from 30 i 32 which does not
implement the copy trade
and then here into it x move
to this method call so over here i'm
moving x and then here i'm trying to
borrow it so what does moving and
borrowing mean
it really means at this point i'm using
up the x value
and so this is how rust basically avoids
memory mistakes it has a
strong concept of ownership every object
at all points is
owned by somebody
and by default objects get moved
like for example in c plus plus
you often have the problem you write a
function and it constructs an object and
then you want to return the object how
do you return the object it's actually
really complicated
in rust you just return the object
because the default is
the function relinquishes the object and
the function that receives the object
just takes ownership
and so that's basically what happens
here the
x is essentially being used up as we
convert it into an iterator and then so
on and the memory in the end
gets owned by the y
now how can we print x then well we
actually have to explicitly clone
and then it works so
those are see and now it works just fine
because
now i i make a clone of x
that i that i run through all this
pipeline and the original x survives and
i can still print it out
so those are the typical pitfalls that
you run into as as
a naive c plus programmer first
encountering
rust i don't need this anymore
i don't need this anymore either okay so
now we now we write fizzbuzz so
now i've written a function buzz
which takes as argument an integer i 32
is a 32-bit integer and then it returns
a tuple
it returns an i32 integer and an
option and we'll get in a second what
this is but let's again let's do it live
let's compile it and run it so
here i'm printing the output from the
buzz function
so what i get is tuples
one comma none two comma none three
comma some fizz
four comma none five comma some bus
so the none and some this is a really
really
rust thing an option
is an object that is either none
or is some of something so here i have
an
option and then of a static string so
that's basically a string
so that's a way in which i can return
either nothing or i can return a string
value
right and so here i'm generating the
results
like my results are these tuples and
it's always the value i
and either none if it doesn't meet any
of these criteria or
sum with a string value buzz fizz
fizzbuzz and so on
and then i have this match which is also
a really rust
thing so i'm writing here i modulo 3
i modulo 5. so i'm creating this tuple
which is i divided or i modulo 3 i
modulo 5
and then i'm saying if that tuple is
0 0 then this is my return value
and if it is 0 comma anything then this
is my return value
and if it is anything comma 0 then this
is my return value and if it is anything
comma
anything so any of the remaining cases
then this is my return value and there's
none here
and so here's the next really beautiful
thing about
rust so let's say you write code like
this
this is i haven't explicitly said this
but this is just commenting out this
line
so i'm just not handling the last case
right
and then the compiler actually tells me
that i have forgotten something
so here if we read the compiler message
ensure that all passable cases are being
handled possibly by adding wild cards or
more match arms
the match value is of type i 32 i32 so
the compiler was smart enough to realize
that there are variations
of of outcomes here that
i have not covered and so therefore it
doesn't compile
and so this is um
[Music]
this is how rust can can be
both a huge pain because it always wants
you to really do
everything all at the same time so for
example i'm
i'm returning an option here which can
be none
or some if i do something else with the
option rather than just printing it
the compiler will always want me to make
sure
that i have some action for if the
result is none
and i have some action for if the result
is sum
i cannot just forget
that there might be a none option and
actually error handling and rust works
the same way
um like instead of like c plus plus has
exceptions and so on and rust you don't
do that you
actually return an object that is sort
of
like an option but it's called a result
and it is
either okay with the value or error
with the value so basically you always
say did i get
a valid result and if so then here's my
valid result
or did i get an error and if so then
here's my error
and then the functions that receive this
return value
they have to handle both cases
the compiler checks whether you you have
something that you will do if the result
is an error
rather than an actual value
um and so this is why like a lot of
people who have experience with rust
they will tell you that oftentimes
when something doesn't compar like they
write code and it doesn't compile and it
can take a long time to get it to
compile because the compiler is so
nitpicky
but once it compiles it typically just
runs
because like the compiler has caught all
the problems
that there could be
so um
now i i lost my train of thought for a
little bit so but what i was trying to
say so it's very typical in other
in rust that you always wrap everything
into
these options and results and so on so
everything is always
wrapped in rust because there's always
well
this could give me a result or no
results so i need to have
both cases covered and so i have it in
an option i have it in a result or i
have a result that contains an option
that contains a result
and so that's where then rust can become
cumbersome
that like every step of the way you
constantly wrap
things into these containers and then
unwrap
them again
okay last pure rust example so now we
combine those two together
and i go straight to the rust playground
and i run it so i have my bus
function here again um
and so now i you see here i apply the
map so again i have this iterator from
one to infinity
i use my map function to apply
the bus function here which takes an it
an integer as its argument it returns
this
tuple of the integer and the option
and then i again apply the filter and so
here z dot one that's the second element
so z dot zero would be the first element
c dot one is the second element
and then is sum tests whether i actually
did get something
and so i keep those and so then you see
three sum
fists five sunbursts six some fists nine
some fish and so on
so alternatively i could write is none
for example and then i keep
exactly the others right
or just to show you um
so z dot zero is just the integer so
let's only keep results
once i've counted to 10 right so now
it's 11
12 13. now i show you another
kind of example of where coc plus plus
programmers constantly fall into the
trap so
let's say i just want to be sure that
the number is greater than 10.5 for
whatever reason i mean sometimes you
have
scenarios like that right um
you have an integer and you want it to
be bigger than a floating point number
yeah you can't do that
right you cannot compare an integer to a
floating point number because rust will
say those are different types
and that is not possible um
also just like a very quick example of
of that so let
y equals 3.5 print y
so i'm i'm completely skipping the bus
function here now and i just
what did i do wrong oh yeah rust also
complains a lot if you have code that is
never used but this is just the warning
and here's my output 3.5 so i just
assign this variable
and then so let's make this
mutable because by default it's not
and now i don't remember whether i put
mute in the right location but we will
see
i'm not that experienced with rust yet
[Music]
but this is what i want to do i want to
increment y by two let's see if this
works
and it doesn't no implementation for
float plus integer
you cannot just add a flow to an integer
that is not okay
so these kinds of things are
um i mean there's reasons why it works
like this
right it really is the the
the two programming designs is no
compromises performance and no
compromises undefined behavior
so everything is explicit in rust
everything has been has to be done with
intention
so if i want this to be
i think this works
yeah see i have to convert
my number two into a floating point
number
f32 is a floating point number 32-bit
um and then i can add it to this number
here which
is also a floating point number so rust
will never
do these kinds of implicit type
conversions for you
it always wants you to explicitly
say what you want
now it has a lot of convenience features
like it will
actually figure out like i can do this
as a 64
and it will also work because it will
actually
figure out that that then this y
apparently also has to be
a 64-bit floating point
number um it's
it's not in the grand scheme of things
that much work
but it's very very confusing if
you are not used to thinking about your
types
in ex in extreme detail and minute
precision
okay so this was some some examples of
what you can do with rus the kind of
high level programming
um the the compiler
looking out for you and also the
compiler complaining about things that
you probably weren't expecting okay so
now
let's get to rust and r so how do we get
those two to talk to each other and so
this is where the extender project
comes in so that's both a rust crate so
in rust libraries are called crates and
then an r package
and i really have to sorry so we have
the extender rust crate
and we have the r extender our package
um and i really have to give
like a hundred and fifty percent of the
credit to
andy thomason he's he's the one who had
the original idea for
for the extender project
and he basically did all the heavy
lifting and is still doing all the heavy
lifting on the rust side
um i i do not want to
give any impression that that i have
written extender i have not i just
found it last fall and realized like
the the r code that i had written that
was talking to rust
i wrote a lot of c bridge code like
hundreds of lines of c code like
rust makes it actually quite easy to
talk to c and so r can talk to c
and rust can talk to c and so you can
write glue code and c
that talks to both languages but that's
really cumbersome
and really annoying and so after a while
i was i was frustrated and i ran into
issues where i was like
i'm just spending way too much time
writing this glue code manually
there must be a better way and the
better way is the extender
project that andy has been developing
and i've started
helping a bit and there's a few other
people that lately have been
working quite a bit on this but i drew
them smaller because really andy
is the one who who who initiated the
project
and has the overarching vision on the on
the rust side of how it should work
okay and then one one thing that is kind
of different
if you're used to something like rc plus
plus or cpp11
you don't need the r extender package to
write
our packages using rust so
our extender is kind of like dev tools
for extender
so if you write an r package
that makes use of the extender code
that package does not have to depend on
our extender
i know that it that it's a bit
confusing initially there's a lot of
moving parts
um so uh
let's just forge ahead and if you want
to dip your toes and you just start
somewhere and hopefully after a while
you see how the
how the parts fit together but let's
just look into okay how can we
have rust and ah talk to each other
and so the first question is okay how
can we write our code that calls russ
code
so functions so this
is a simple function in rust which
takes two floating point values and then
returns a floating point value and it
just adds those two
and then this is a rust macro rust so i
told you that there's this
great extendable macro programming
language and so that allows us to do
things like we just so um
[Music]
if you look at a lot of rust code you
find these
sort of decorations where it's a hashtag
and then square brackets and then
there's something
in those square brackets and that
is a way in rust to call a macro that
does a computation
on the function of the object that
follows this decoration
and then produces something and so um
and this is this is just a library
statement this just pulls in
the the dependencies from the
extender package but this is what does
all the magic because this one line
of rust macro code
basically generates all the stuff that
is needed
to then be able to call this function
from
r and then in r you literally just do
add float
and this is the result
so this is functions we can also do
objects so this is a simple
counter object in rust so we have a
struct here which is
just an object containing multiple
variables
and it has a variable n which is an
integer
and then we have three functions here
new which just
sets n to zero increment
which just increments n by one
and get which returns the value
and then in r you can use it as such
you can create a new counter and then
x dollar get gives you the current value
which is zero and then
x dollar increment increments it and
then x dollar get
again gives you the value
so we can from our
talk to functions and talk to objects
which means we can pretty much
do everything anything that we might
want
from r to rust so so that works great if
you have some you have some high
performance computing library in
written and rust and you just want to
use it and r
that works great but the moment you want
to work between those two languages you
probably also have to
go the other way around right you also
in your rust code you have to call
r also and so i'm showing you a few
examples
of this also so i have a note at the
bottom
so the code that i'm
showing is valid for extender 0.2 which
is what is currently
released on crates.io
we have made some changes to the api
that will be published eventually
um so for now though these these
examples work
and i can tell you actually
in this line of code what exactly the
changes but what am i doing here so let
data equals
r exclamation mark so this is again
this is rust code right this is
a rust macro and it actually
takes r code as an argument
and converts it like it
it actually processes it it and runs it
and then here i have
a rust variable that contains
the r object that was generated
from this code and the question mark is
error handling
it basically it just makes sure that if
there was an error that happened here
the error is handled properly i don't
i don't want to go into the details of
how we do error handling and rust
now the one thing that we have changed
since then now we actually take this in
quotes
it turns out it wasn't a good idea to
try to
actually take raw r code in rust
because the rust parser has a slightly
different
idea of what valid identifiers are then
the
then like ah has identifiers with
periods in them and the rust compiler
really doesn't
like those um so now
we are in we're discouraging now this
format and say you really
should put your r code in quotes anyway
so this is one way you can do it and
then
you can print this so again this is this
is
rust code but this is a macro
that also extender provides which does
an
r print so it it prints the output
but through the r channel so the output
is properly
um handled on the r side it doesn't just
go to standard out and wherever your
current standard out is it pops up
um so so this is just a proper
handling of printing in an r environment
and then we can also
iterate over this object in in rust and
print out the output
and so on and so then here
you see this little r exclamation mark
so this is a little bit
confusing and we've been thinking a lot
about
whether it's right or not but i think we
have agreed that it's right
so capital r exclamation mark means
take r code and turn it into an
r object in rust lowercase exclamation
mark means
take rust code and turn it into an
r object in rust
and so this for example is just a vector
in rust and so you can see
how how elegant and how easy that is if
i want in my rust code
a representation of a vector of these
five numbers i can just
write this and the result is an r object
that i could like return
in in a function called back to r
or do further processing with it or so
on and i think i'll actually
if we have enough time later i'll i'll
show this in a in a live demo maybe
um two more two more things and then i'm
done with my presentation
one is so in an r session if you have
the r
extender library installed and you have
a proper
rust build environment setup then you
can just create a rust function
with this call rust function and then
so this function add and then i have it
in my r session here
and you can also do it in your r
markdown actually like
all the code examples are this
presentation is made with our markdown
and all the examples actually live
compiled
um so
for example this is so we wrote this
new chunk type extender and so this is
just rust code in our markdown and then
our markdown compiles it
and runs it and renders it and you might
say well how do i know that this was
actually compiled
well you can return the result from rus
to r
by just so so in rus the convention is
if there's a semicolon then it's just a
statement
but if there's no semicolon then it's a
return value
so this z at the very end
is the return value from this whole
block of rust code
and it actually gets returned and
printed here
in the rendered markdown document
so you see here in rust 5 times 7
is 35 and i return the value it's 35
that's actually exactly what happened
here right i generated this rust
variable data and then i returned it
from rus to r and it's a typical that i
generated and so
it's printed here
[Music]
and you can also so this the last bit is
maybe for somebody wants to write a book
about rust so you can actually make
multiple chunks and then chain them
together so
then you could write something like this
like define variable x
let x equals y one define variable y let
y equals two
print i print it out and this is my
output
and so i want to close with this most
people overestimate what they can do in
one year and underestimate
what they can do in 10 years remember
my real goal is improve text rendering
in gg plot right and
i i got sidetracked improving the
the interaction between r and rust
because ultimately i want to use
these servo libraries that are written
in rust
in my r package and so um
i i'm okay if that takes a little longer
right i had a working prototype last
summer and now
this year is just spent working on
extender and eye extender and getting
that
to a place where it's usable and
functional and maybe next year
go back to improving text rendering and
maybe in 10 years
um we will actually be able to to do
see to do css styling in ggplot plots
that's my long-term
goal with all of this and so with that i
have
just various links to resources at the
end and that was about an hour so
so that's good right so let me maybe
just
for five minutes do a live demo just to
show you that this is actually
all real and not just me
making it up um
so here is here is my uh
studio i haven't shared it yet
okay so first of all this is actually
the r markdown that created
the talk it takes a bit to knit
because it does actually compile all the
rust code in there
if i if i turn it on so i have like
compile rust if i set compilers to false
then it knits fast i don't think i'll do
it now because it'll pop out
in a separate window that is not going
to be
shared anyway so let's forget about that
and let's just do an r
extender live demo so this is here i'm
creating my rust function
this is a new session whenever you start
a new session the first time you compile
a rust function
rust will download all the dependencies
that it needs and will compile them so
it takes a little bit of time
and you will see that i have a somewhat
non-standard setup my console is down
here
so you will see down here the output
from the compilation so i
run this and so it's building here you
see it's compiling all the
various dependencies takes about
60 seconds or so the first time
you do this so
it's compiling the extender api now it's
compiling this and now so that it's not
too bad right
and now i have this function here and it
actually works
right now i can add two numbers
uh and it works
okay and just to show you the second
time you compile it it's much faster
because it
cache caches uh the various
things that it has compiled
the various dependencies and so this is
uh then there's also rust source
which takes not just one function but a
larger object
and so here i'm i'm having this example
with the class
so i compiled it and now here
count a new counter get increment
twice counter get two so this also
works
right and then i said i wanted to
demonstrate
uh the the little r macro
so let's just do something on the fly
make vector
and let's just not take anything
here um now it's dangerous i'm not sure
i know what i'm doing
let's just try this anyway
if this doesn't work forgive me i'm not
andy andy could do this um
i'm just pretending i know what i'm
doing but i think this will work
uh let's see if it compiles it compiled
very good so make vector
haha see so this shows you how easy
it is
so this part here this is a vector in
rust right
this these are just um
it doesn't have to be sequential
and then the r exclamation mark
generates
it takes rust code and turns it into an
r
object and so um i mean this is maybe
somewhat uh boring because it's just a
hard coded vector but it just to show
you that it's really easy
to generate even complex objects like if
you know how to program in rust
you will it you will find it very easy
to say generate
vectors or other complex objects and
shuffle them
into r or back and forth write code that
takes an
r vector and and process it in rust
and so on um and i think
that's that's a good point to to stop
here and maybe
take some questions
great thank you everyone let's give a
virtual applause i'll give a golf clap
over the screen so it's not too loud but
everyone
virtual applause for a wonderful talk
so thank you very much um if people have
more questions feel free to ask them
i'll start with what i have written down
and uh feel free for people to uh please
jump in um
the very first question is which rust
book did you get
uh oh yeah i uh
i don't remember what what is it it's on
my
nightstand somewhere over there uh let
me
see if i can find it on amazon quickly
um yeah why don't you ask the next
question i'll just
look and actually all right
so in a few observations rather than
questions um you mentioned daniel
falbell
fable um he actually recently spoke at
the meetup in the past couple of months
um and it was really awesome he gave
talk about torch so it seems like
daniel's just like good about
translating languages to r in general
i'm guessing
so my understanding is i don't want to
talk
for him but he uh there is some sort of
sorry i should know
what it's so he found a library that he
needs for his machine
learning things that is in rust and so
that's why he wants i think it's topic
modeling
if i remember correctly so basically
there are some
i mean rust is still a very young
language only about 10 years old or so
but slowly there are some libraries that
really
the best version is available in rust
and so that's what currently we are
looking
for things like like we have really a
working
um a good working
setup now but now we need some killer
application right
the thing that you can only do in rust
that will demonstrate that this
absolutely is needed and so i think for
him it was
like in his concert context of building
and he's riding the torch package right
and he wants to
add this i'm pretty sure it's topic
modeling but i'm not entirely sure
but anyway there's this rust library
that he wants to integrate and that's
why he's
using this nice and that brings to mind
something that you talked
to me about on twitter a while ago is
are there the equivalent of our of
armadillo or eigen
for rust though you do like matrix
multiplication nicely and easily
i really don't know that
andy would be like if you want more
about like
technical workings of rust and so on
you should invite andy to give a talk
and it might actually
be a good follow-up like i gave you the
high level introduction
and andy would really be the person to
to go into the mechanics of
in particular mechanics of rust which i
still feel like a total rust newbie
so i i found the book here i can just
put the link into the chat
um it's called programming rust
um and i will take that and i will put
that into the slack channel because i'm
not sure you're in the slack channel
i'm not yeah all right all right so
folks um
class just put it in the zoom chat and i
just put it into the slack channel so
everyone has access to it
all right um then before we dive into
more questions another observation
um the amount of live coding in this
talk that has actually worked is pretty
astounding so
kudos for that well i i practiced a few
times
even though actually a few of the
examples
like when i modified the code were not
necessarily practiced yeah
yeah that's that's brave this is very
brave i'm glad they worked
uh so then this is actually it was a
comment but i'm going to turn it into a
question
you when you did your early example with
the dot take of 10
and like you took 10 of the numbers out
of the infinite range what if you didn't
do that
like would this thing compute an
infinite number of numbers would it
eventually have like
it would exit the infinite loop but what
would happen uh i mean we can try it out
right we have it
set up live um
in the in the playground i
i don't know i would suspect
okay now this is really like
i would expect the compiler to complain
yeah i would too
okay i'll share my screen again
so here it is right so this
runs just fine
and so you're saying well what if we
remove this
right
are we now bringing down the rust
playground
this will be fun to see
okay so so it actually created an
infinite loop so it did compile
um arguably i mean the compiler protects
you from
uh from undefined behavior and this is
not
undefined right i mean you want just
all the numbers in a vector and
that's a perfectly well defined problem
it just happens to be
too big for your computer to handle
so okay so now we know the compiler will
not catch this i mean nobody ever
claimed that the compiler would catch
everything it just catches a lot
still still pretty good that's pretty
good
all right um then in one of your code
where you put one of your slides of code
you were showing uh
the match function after like one of the
last arms there was still a comma after
the last arm
uh why so so that's sort of a rust
thing that you can always have a final
comma
and the idea is that
like and actually since i've i've
started programming rust
i hate that r doesn't do this like how
many times do you have like a list of
things with comma and then the last one
doesn't have a comma
and then you want to add one more and
then you have to add the comma and then
the first time you forget the comma
right and then it doesn't work or then
you want to comment one out and then
like again it doesn't work right and
and so the rust language is just you can
always have a final comma and it will
get ignored
and so that just makes it very easy to
like comment out an arm or add one or so
yeah so that's nice
that's really nice cool
thanks that's a great i like that
um we had a question just come in and
i'll slip that in
order that's fine for me um with rust
strict ownership rules is it easy hard
or impossible to set up distributed
computing problems using rust
so first of all i know nothing about
distributed computing
but in in general the question is
always do you have an acyclic
graph or do you have a cyclic graph
right like if you have a tree structure
if you can cleanly divide
your entire object into two pieces and
you give one here and you give one there
then it's trivial because at all
there's no crosstalk right the the
problem is
the moment you have some sort of
cyclicality and like there's an entire
book
it's actually also a good book to read
i'll i'll put the link here let me
quickly find it
it's let me google it and then i'll read
the title
because i want to get the title right
it's it's just too funny
uh actually i'll i'll share my screen
again
so this is the
maybe i should just keep it shared
learn rust with entirely too many linked
lists
so the entire book is about learning
rust and all it does is
trying to implement a linked list in
rust
which is uh basically impossible
i mean there's this sentence here linked
lists are so truly awful that you deal
with all of these concepts in making
them real
basically you have to learn every
archaic
weird thing of russ to build a linked
list because it
rust really doesn't want you to build a
linked list
because linked lists don't really have
clear ownership patterns right
um and and so i think that's
so it's just like when it's shared i
find it confusing so
um the the point is
this for any computing problem that you
may have
there is an approach that will work just
fine in rust
but sometimes you have to really rethink
how you're implementing things and if
you have written a lot of linked lists
in your life
and that's just your go-to approach
then you'll have a hard time
and if you if you can
move away from that and find the the
appropriate data structure that rust
likes then it's going to be very easy
very cool thank you i'm going to
continue on
uh the list but uh before i do actually
during this whole pandemic while we've
been doing virtual
i've gotten future speakers by seeing
them in the list of attendees
so i'm going to call it a few people who
just i see the name right now um
emil and ian um i want you both to speak
so please email me um i otherwise i'll
have to find you
so emil and ian please uh send me a
message if you don't know my email
address
find me on twitter jaredlander.com
something i've
been following your stuff a lot so
message me and you'll be you'll be
speaking sooner than you realize
and this is a shameless as a guest we do
this literally um a few months ago
miles mcbain was speaking and i found
both will landau and henrik
oh man henrik's last name is escaping me
right now henrik and will
we found them both in the audience hey
you two are giving talks and they did
that's as simple as it happens here so
ian in the middle you're on notice you
have to give a talk
all right so with that we have a few our
questions and
our rest questions and some rust
questions like what is
these are two linked ones so what is the
ampersand mutt or mute and what is the
ampersand apostrophe
in the option ampersand apostrophe
static string
yeah those are two very different
concepts so
the ampersand is actually easy that's
like a reference
so if you're familiar with c plus plus
references
it's the same so in rust it's called
boring i was just looking where in my
i know it's the okay here so
okay i'll share again um
so the ampersand wait there was
was there one earlier without that it
came later in the side deck if i recall
it's
ampersand mutt or mute or you know um
you might have done it on live yeah this
one here ampersand itself
that's another one so so that is really
just like you would think of it in in c
plus right so this takes
uh remember i said by default objects
get moved well what if you don't want to
move it right
what if you just want a reference to an
object
rather than the object itself and so in
a function call
you would write it like this ampersand
self and then you
just get a reference to the object
rather than the object itself
but because you get a reference
this by default is not mutable
so what this really means is
this function offset it can read from
the self
but it cannot write and so so this is
just like in c
plus it's a very cheap way to get read
access to an object
object doesn't have to get copied the
object doesn't
doesn't change ownership and
[Music]
you can have as many references
read-only references to an object as you
want now a mute with an ampersand that
means you have a reference that is
mutable
and so there the compiler actually keeps
track
you can only ever have one mutable
reference at a time
and that's actually what makes it for
example threat safe
and also protects from from undefined
behavior
like if one part of the code has a
mutable reference
then another part at the same time
cannot have a mutable reference
and the compiler makes sure that that's
always the case
and so this is actually where then
this comes in so this is a lifetime
so when you talk about references i just
said well you cannot have
ever have two mutable references to the
same object
at the same time well how do you know
what at the same time means
right um and so that's where lifetimes
come in so for example this
static means this is a permanent
lifetime this exists as long as the
program runs
and other lifetimes could be for example
if you have a function
and then the function creates an object
and then creates a reference and gives
it to another function
by default the lifetime of that object
is the lifetime
of the function that generated the
object
right so lifetimes i kind of
scopes for references if you wish they
they define
for how long a reference is in existence
and so that allows you to be sure that
the
first of all to be sure that you don't
have two mutable references to the same
object
but also to be sure that the reference
does not out exist the actual object
right so if i'm creating a string with a
static lifetime then the rust compiler
actually makes
sure that the actual object that the
reference refers to
exists as long as the reference exists
which in this time in this case is
permanent
right um and so so
all of these things so those are the
little traps that you run into when you
start learning rust
that suddenly the compiler complains
about the wrong lifetime the compiler
says well here you're trying to borrow
so borrowing this is borrowing in in
rust speak
it's basically taking a reference rather
than taking the object itself so you're
just borrowing the object
and then the compiler will say well
you're trying to borrow
an object mutably but there's still
a mutable reference somewhere and so you
can't do that now
and so that's then where you really have
to
retrain your brain to to think the way
that rust thinks about things
but that's also what what allows the
threat safety and so on because rust
always knows where things are mutable or
not
how long they can be existence and so it
can
make sure that that you don't get any
race conditions basically
okay great
so yeah it's definitely understandable c
plus plus but i assume
makes it similar are there
any commonly used r packages that you
think would benefit
from having portions re-implemented in
rust and then a follow-up
how do packages of a rust requirement
fare on crayon
two separate questions but well it's the
first one are there anything in r that
you think would really do well if you
re rooted part of it and rust
so uh i don't
i don't really know um that question it
really
so if if
i now were to start from scratch
some sort of high performance package
i would rather implement it in rust than
c
plus honestly so but but
does it make sense to take an existing
package and rewrite
into rust probably not so then the only
question is do you have
like a library in rust that is better
than the equivalent in c
or c plus plus maybe
i don't know there may be some that
exist like that
uh and then how do packages with a rust
requirement
fair on crown the real problem so first
of all
there are yeah there are some like the
gifski package
is probably the most widely used and
most famous one
and that actually is a rust library to
make gifs
and the gifski package just wraps that
library
it does not use the extender framework
as actually as far as i know
no package on cran currently uses
extender
like all the packages on cron that use
rust
use the c route which actually is not
that much more complicated
like if you have a simple c api that you
want to
expose like like some rust libraries
have a c api and then it's actually
like the gives key rust library has a c
api and that's actually very easy to
expose to r but i think going forward
like honestly extender until point two
which we released
in january or february it really wasn't
even in a stage that
anybody could use it and now like um we
did a lot of work mostly last fall and
over the winter to
to make it usable to make sure it
actually compiles on all
widely used systems like windows was a
huge
pain but we got it to work there also
and so on
um the problem with getting it on cran
is that basically for windows
you need to pre-compile the windows
library and then you need to download
as it gets built on cran and gifski does
that also actually
you need to write a little bit of code
that instead of compiling the library
for windows it just
downloads the library for windows and
then
then com compiles it so you download a
static library of just the rust part and
then you use the r linker to link it
it's a bit annoying um
but i've been told that even like c and
c
plus plus packages often operate like
that
that they don't actually compile it a
new
for windows on cran but rather have a
pre-compiled version that just gets
linked in
torch does that you know it um downloads
tor lib torch
rather than building it around crayon
because it's too big it's a gigabyte now
yeah yeah and so so basically you'd have
to do
the at present you'd have to do the same
for your rust
libraries i hope that eventually
that'll go away that rust becomes
sufficiently widely used that we can
rely
that a rust compiler is available on
cran but currently
you can't rely on that yet
so you sort of answer the question i see
here
[Music]
does the same code work across linux
windows and mac so
um sort of it seems not quite yet it
seems
no no no it does so i mean like
we have a continuous integration
set up for
linux windows mac mac m1
and actually windows 32 and 64 bit so we
spent
a lot of time making sure all of that
works
windows 32 there's a few thread safety
things
that don't work and that apparently is a
limitation of windows 32 but i just
learned that windows 32 will be phased
out in
two years time so
we'll be very glad when that happens
well you know you you know cram makes
you support solaris
so who knows if you'll be lost to
support windows 32 also for cran
well the the important thing is so we
basically we want to
spawn like when when you call a rust
function we actually spawn the rust
function in a separate thread
so if anything goes wrong in that thread
we can safely
catch that and break it down and return
safely to r without crashing and that
feature does not work in windows 32 in
all
scenarios there's scenarios like and
then
the most frustrating scenario is
actually if you from your rust code
call an r function
that creates a long jump so that
basically
triggers an error so then we have to
catch the error in rust
and then properly like hand it back to r
and that works everywhere except windows
32
and it's a limitation of of the compiler
on windows 32 or something like that i
don't
exactly remember the details but it just
doesn't work
sounds like an extreme edge case you
found
yeah i mean if you if you're like deep
in the weeds and trying to like have
these two languages talk to each other
that both
of the opinion that they own the world
that that's really the problem right i
mean
ah thinks it owns the world and rust
thinks it owns the world and like i uses
long jumps and
rust things long jumps are a terrible
idea and
those two things together are a bit
tricky
i get that um
and you i think mentioned c plus plus
which goes nicely to this question
like an rcpp that you can pass in
vectors
add the vectors of syntactic sugar like
the vector x plus the vector y
not use a loop or anything so because a
can you
pass vectors and return vectors from
rust and b is there any syntactic sugar
if you want to like add two vectors and
multiply two vectors
so i i showed you the syntactic sugar of
returning vectors right i
showed you that you can do that and
yes you can also um so we
we're like still figuring out how
exactly we want things to be
set up um
so the original idea that andy had was
that
we convert as much as possible our data
types into native
rust data types automatically
and that's a great idea until it's not
um so where it gets problematic
is okay so r can have missing values
right so how do you convert them into
rust
well then the native version of rust
would be an option
so then really an r vector turns into a
vector of
options in rust
right um and so right now basically the
the way that we have settled on is that
that you get whatever object makes sense
depending on what you write in your
function signature
like if i write as my argument vector of
integer on the right side then i get a
vector of integers
and if they're missing values then i'll
get an error
because the rust code expects an integer
and the missing value is not an integer
so i get an error
if i would rather automatically generate
it
right it'll just say this is the wrong
input for this function
if i would rather be able to handle the
missing values
then i have to make the input a vector
of
options and then my rust code needs to
handle this
and so then the syntactic sugar
so short answer is we don't have it
currently but i mean if you write a
function if you say i only want vectors
of numeric values you could just
write that in your rust function as the
function signature
and then you have negative vectors of of
numeric values and then you handle them
however you would handle them
in rust um and rust is actually
really good about dealing with
with iterators and like multiple
iterators and so on so you probably
wouldn't even have to write a for loop
to add the two vectors together but i
don't
um it's not a vectorized language like r
is but
but as a very powerful set of
of of constructs to deal with vectors
um i don't know if this it sort of was a
roundabout way of answering your
question of course
yeah it's like you know like rcp you
could do x plus y and it translates
underneath the hood to
for loop for you automatically i guess
you know that same thing
and i guess in a similar vein here um
when you go from an r vector to a rust
vector
is it copying the data if i pass it a
huge vector is it duplicating the memory
in the computer
because i know like i think in with a
sex p object
it the r object is the same as xp in
terms of the memory it takes up
so i do that with rust is it going to
copy the data or is it going to
reference
the data so it it
really depends on how you take the
argument
at that point and so um
you can actually so and this is
really where where
sort of there's a big shift in the api
from
0.2 which is published to 0.3 which is
on github but it's not
like released i shouldn't say publish
really i mean it's all
publicly available but it's not released
the original version was uh
that you do the native conversion
and so that means if if you want
actually to
take procession of the object then you
would create a copy
um and and now andy has implemented what
he calls
wrappers which is sort of like um
a c plus plus numeric vector or
something like that
which by default
keeps it as a reference and only makes a
copy if you need a copy
so basically the way it is is
you can do any way you want it to and
like um
you can you cannot worry about it and
and just
take it as as an actual value that you
process and then it'll make a copy or
you can worry a little more about it and
have an object that wraps
the r object and doesn't make a copy
until you explicitly
request the copy okay
so yeah all these options are available
it just it may require a little more
knowledge of how what exactly it does
depending on which code you write
and to some extent we're still even
figuring out what the correct patterns
are
and speaking of patterns goes to the
next question um when you showed writing
a function in rust from r
you do like rust source and in quotes or
at the rope the rust function
what if you want to have like like a
rust source file
and then like you know if our cpp is
i'll relate it back to you like a
cpp file you decorate it and then it
becomes compiled so
how would you work if you want to put
all your functions written as actual
rust code
and then build our functions out of them
what's the workflow
so are you talking about writing a
package or are you just talking about
like the
equivalent to cpp source
let's say both okay because they're very
different
but i actually demonstrated one of the
two
there is the so i actually
uh i wrote the r extender package by
basically
reading the cpp11 package and just
like replacing c stuff with
with rust stuff so
if you look at this so this is rust
function
but we also have sorry where is it
oh i sorry i'm sharing the wrong
i i had it in my interactive
demonstration
which uh
is here
okay found it
my cat is complaining i'm not exactly
sure
why he's complaining about something
so here i have rust source and it takes
code and so this is uh
you can do more than just one function
right so
you may notice the difference is here i
don't have to add the
hashtag extender because rust function
assumes it's just one function it
adds that behind the scenes
versus rustsource just takes some
longer amount of rust code and just
compiles the whole thing
and you could also provide a file rather
than like
rather than doing it inline you could
just give the name of a file
and then it'll just take that and
compile that
if that has like three functions in it
all three would be exposed to r in the
environment at that point
yes cool yes so we can just
do this here let's give it a different
name
but we need to we need to decorate it
with the extender thing
otherwise it doesn't work
that's awesome
all right so theoretically instead of
saying code equals you could have done
file equals
and pointed to a dot rust file dot rst
whatever it's called
that's correct yeah very nice
yeah and then the other thing that we
and we just
implemented that um but i won't dare to
to demonstrate that live because uh
i think it works correctly but it's like
so i like about two months ago i i
stopped working on rxtender because i'm
teaching
a database class this spring that i've
never taught before and i'm spending all
my time preparing lectures and so i just
had to
like shove the r extender to the side
for a little bit
um but i'm pretty sure it works now
so there's like use this type functions
that you can use to like you
said say set up a package structure
and then you run use extender
and it'll set up the entire
infrastructure that you need
to have a rust component in your r
package
and it's actually very little
actually i can probably show this on
github
oh i thought let's get that live demo
sorry
i thought we were about to get that live
demo no sorry
uh i'll show you
the hello extender so we we made
a simple
uh demo so so this package was
originally
originally written as an example of how
like the minimal example to use extender
in an r package
but now you don't even need this anymore
because you can just like
use the rx then they use
use extender function to do that
but so in the source um
[Music]
you have makevas they're a little bit
complex but basically you just need to
copy over the way they look
and then you have entry points so then
unfortunately
we need one c file because somehow
ah if there is no c file at all
i will say there's no sources here
there's nothing for us to do
so you just need to declare this
function
and call it like
it's going to be always these three
lines and it just this is your package
name
um so the comment explains we need to
forward routine registration from c to
rust to avoid the linker removing the
static library
i don't know why it does that but it
does that so it's really annoying
and then here in the rus
we have our rust source here
and so we need to declare this
extender api and then we can have
functions and then the one thing that we
need to do
here that is sort of hidden in the
interactive
rust source functions we actually need
to ex
we need to declare all the parts that we
want to export
so we need to say this is there's a
module called hello extender and it
exports this function so that that's uh
for technical reasons it it be
somewhat long and complicated to explain
why we need this but i mean it's
it's not a lot of work you just list
whatever you want to export you list
here
and that's really it and then on the r
side there are these wrappers
that then call
the rust function but this is actually
auto-generated
so um if you think about it i i had a
rust function that is called add and
then
in the r session i just type add well
what what is it calling it's calling
actually an r function that then calls a
rust function
but these are auto-generated so you
don't really ever
have to have to worry about
where they come from and so this really
takes advantage of of these powerful
macro programming
features of rust in that
as you compile the rust library
the compiler actually generates
this code basically or generates code
that then can
write out this code
that's nice that's very nice and so if
you if you know a bit about how like
rcpp and cpp11 do it they
like have like a separate library
that tries to pass the c plus plus code
and find these decorators and try to
interpret it
and so we basically avoid all of this
in in extender because
like this and this is
actually processed by the rust compiler
so you will never run into the situation
where somehow
like you have to write your own rust
passing code and then
maybe you don't implement it quite the
same as the rust compiler is
is implemented and then maybe it'll
break in in some
settings or so we can avoid all of that
because it's actually
all processed by the rust compiler as it
compiles the source code
that's awesome that's really nice
cool then one last question that we'll
call tonight
there's been a lot of questions um when
you showed our markdown
in an extender chunk you actually like
had the rust code what if you wanted to
to define a function like a rust
function
in the r markdown chunk then use that as
an r function in a different chunk later
on in an arc chunk
so i did that oh you did that okay then
do you answer the question uh let me
[Music]
actually
okay so this is
this is the package site for the r
extender
package which actually i i had hoped to
have it on cran
before this uh talk
and then my my class was just too much
work
but so here is using rust code in our
markdown documents
this documents all of that
and so uh
exporting rust functions or objects to r
so let's first look at
so see here i have rust code
for example a simple function that just
returns a string
and then i can use it here
wonderful and and so the way the this is
the markdown so
there's actually two different chunks so
extender source
that's actually the equivalent of rust
source so you can write an extended
amount of code
that all gets processed versus just
extender just takes one function
got it sorry that's incorrect
extender is more like rust eval it just
takes
individual statements and evaluates them
so whenever you want to actually export
functions you have to use extender
source
and then you have to use these extender
decorations
for functions or classes and then
they get exported and you can use them
in your markdown
and you can even so this is this is the
beauty
of like how everything is integrated in
rust
so here i'm actually um
using this uh rust crate
pull down c mark which is a markdown
passing library and i'm
i'm setting up my dependency here i'm
saying
i need a tendency pull down c mark
version 0.8
and then it actually finds it downloads
it compiles it as you
you just knit your markdown it does all
of that and so now here i've
like in five lines i've written
a markdown to html converter
so here md to html
it takes the markdown and converts it to
html
and this is the actual rust code
that does that so it takes a string as
input and then
it needs to set up some options and then
creates a parser and then
here creates the html and then returns
the output to r
that's awesome so this is why i think
like
at this point russ is still very young
so we don't have a lot of
like unique and powerful libraries but
once like as they
come about it'll be really really easy
to expose them to r
with this framework yeah it looks like
it
cool well thank you very much i went
through our entire list of questions
uh thank you for the wonderful
presentation so everyone who's here uh
ran out another round of virtual
applause
uh for klaus for that a wonderful talk
hope everyone can clap along with emojis
or even quietly at home we'll assume
you're clapping for
for him um that's fantastic you know i
got a lot out of it i hope everyone else
did too
i see a bunch of people are clapping in
both the um the chat
and in the slack channel so thank you
um if everyone can remember next month
may 17th will we have a light gbm talk
and more to come after that you have a
bunch more clapping in there
so thank you very much and everyone hope
you have a wonderful safe night
and i hope everything just gets better
and better as the year goes on people
saying thank you so much
getting you don't see it on the slack
but a lot of people are clapping there
so thank you thank you everyone for
attending thank you class and hopefully
i'll see you soon next month at the comp
and
in the future events and at the
conference and everything else talk to
that everybody
thank you for having me bye thanks for
coming here
thanks for speaking